On nous a dit de prendre des risques et de dire quelque chose de surprenant.
Je tâcherai donc de faire ça. Mais
je tiens à commencer par deux choses que tout le monde sait déjà.
La première chose, en fait,
est connue depuis pratiquement le début de notre histoire écrite.
La planète Terre, ou le système solaire,
ou notre environnement ou peu importe,
est spécifiquement adaptée pour supporter notre évolution -- ou création, ainsi que nous la considérions alors --
notre existence actuelle, et plus important, notre survie future.
De nos jours, cette idée possède un nom spectaculaire: le Vaisseau Terre.
L'idée est qu'en dehors du vaisseau,
l'univers est implacablement hostile,
et que l'intérieur est tout ce que nous avons, tout ce dont nous dépendons.
Nous n'avons droit qu'à une chance: si nous saccageons le vaisseau,
nous ne pouvons aller nulle part ailleurs.
La seconde chose que tout le monde sait déjà est que
contrairement à ce que l'on a cru tout au long de l'histoire humaine,
les êtres humains ne sont pas, en fait, au centre de ce qui existe.
Comme l'a si notoirement dit Stephen Hawking,
nous sommes juste un dépôt chimique à la surface d'une banale planète
en orbite autour d'une banale étoile,
située dans la banlieue d'une banale galaxie, etc...
Seulement, la première de ces deux choses que tout le monde sait
dit d'une certaine façon que c'est un lieu
très atypique, spécifiquement adapté, etc...
la seconde dit que nous sommes dans un endroit banal.
En particulier, si vous considérez ces deux choses comme des vérités profondes
susceptibles de guider votre existence et d'éclairer vos choix de vie,
alors elles semblent être un tantinet en conflit l'une envers l'autre.
Mais ça ne les empêche pas d'être toutes les deux complètement fausses. (Rires)
Et elles le sont réellement. Laissez-moi donc commencer par la seconde :
Banal. Bien -- ce lieu est-il banal ? Bon, regardons autour de nous,
regardons dans une direction au hasard, et nous voyons un mur, et euh... un dépôt chimique -- (Rires)
-- et cela n'a rien de banal dans l'univers.
Tout ce que vous avez à faire est de parcourir quelques centaines de kilomètres dans cette même direction et de vous retourner,
et vous ne verrez ni mur, ni dépôt chimique du tout --
tout ce que vous verrez est une planète bleue. Et si vous allez plus loin encore,
vous verrez le soleil, le système solaire, et les étoiles, etc...
Mais ce n'est toujours pas typique de l'univers, parce que les étoiles forment des galaxies.
Et la plupart des endroits dans l'univers, un endroit banal dans l'univers,
n'est en aucun cas près d'une galaxie.
Alors allons plus loin, jusqu'à sortir de la galaxie, et retournons-nous,
et ouais, il y a cette énorme galaxie avec ses bras en spirales disposée devant nous.
A ce point, nous sommes arrivés à 100000 années-lumière d'ici.
Mais nous ne sommes toujours pas proche d'un endroit banal dans l'univers.
Pour atteindre un endroit typique,
nous devons aller mille fois plus loin que cela dans l'espace intergalactique.
Comment est cet endroit ? Banal.
A quoi ressemble un endroit banal dans l'univers ?
Eh bien, au prix d'une énorme dépense, TED a pu mettre au point une représentation virtuelle immersive,
en haute résolution, de l'espace intergalactique
-- vu depuis l'espace intergalactique.
Donc, peut-on éteindre les lumières, s'il vous plaît, qu'on puisse la voir ?
Bon, pas tout à fait, pas tout à fait parfait -- vous voyez, dans l'espace intergalactique
-- l'espace intergalactique est complètement sombre, noir goudron.
C'est tellement sombre que si vous deviez regarder l'étoile la plus proche de vous,
et que cette étoile explose en une supernova,
et que vous regardiez directement dans sa direction au moment où sa lumière vous atteindrait,
vous ne verriez même pas la moindre lueur.
Tel est l'univers, aussi grand et aussi sombre que ça.
Et cela en dépit du fait qu'une supernova est un événement si lumineux, si brillant,
qu'elle vous tuerait instantanément dans un rayon de plusieurs années-lumière.
Et pourtant, depuis l'espace intergalactique, c'est tellement loin que vous ne la verriez même pas.
Il fait aussi très froid là-bas
-- moins de trois degrés au-dessus du zéro absolu.
Et c'est très vide. Là, le vide est un million de fois moins dense
que le plus haut niveau de vide actuellement obtenu par notre meilleure technologie sur Terre.
Donc voilà au combien un endroit banal est différent de ce lieu-ci.
Et voilà combien ce lieu-ci peut être atypique.
Bien, pourriez-vous rallumer, s'il vous plaît ? Merci.
Maintenant, comment connaissons-nous un environnement qui est si loin,
si différent, et si étranger, de tout ce dont nous avons l'habitude ?
Bien, la Terre -- notre environnement, dans son aspect humain -- crée de la connaissance.
Bon, qu'est-ce que cela signifie ? Eh bien, regardez encore plus loin que là où nous venons d'aller --
je veux dire d'ici, avec un télescope -- et vous verrez des choses qui ressemblent à des étoiles.
On les appelle quasars. "Quasars" signifiait à l'origine objet quasi-stellaire.
Ce qui veut dire des choses qui ressemblent un peu à des étoiles. (Rires) Mais qui n'en sont pas.
Nous savons ce qu'elles sont. Il y a des milliards d'années, à des milliards d'années-lumière,
la matière au centre d'une galaxie s'est effondrée
en un trou noir super massif.
Et dès lors, des champs magnétiques intenses ont dirigé une partie de l'énergie de
l'effondrement gravitationnel. Une partie de la matière
fut rejetée sous la forme de gigantesques jets qui ont illuminé les lobes
avec la brillance de -- je crois que c'est mille milliards de soleils.
La physique d'un cerveau humain ne pourrait guère être plus différente de celle d'un tel jet.
Nous ne pourrions y survivre un instant. Les mots vous manquent
quand vous essayez de décrire l'intérieur d'un de ces jets.
Ce serait un peu comme assister à l'explosion d'une supernova,
mais à bout portant et sur des millions d'années à la fois. (Rires)
Et pourtant, ce jet s'est produit précisément comme il fallait pour que des milliards d'années plus tard,
de l'autre côté de l'univers, quelques bouts de dépôt chimique puissent décrire avec précision,
et modéliser, et prédire, et expliquer, surtout -- voilà votre référence
-- ce qu'il se passait là-bas, en réalité.
Un système physique, le cerveau,
contient un modèle fonctionnel précis de l'autre -- le quasar.
Pas seulement une image superficielle, bien qu'il la contienne aussi,
mais un modèle explicatif, incarnant les mêmes relations
mathématiques et la même structure causale.
Voilà, ça c'est de la connaissance.Et si ce n'était pas assez stupéfiant,
la fidélité avec laquelle l'une des structures ressemble à l'autre
s'accroît avec le temps. C'est la croissance de la connaissance.
Les lois de la physique ont cette propriété particulière,
que les objets physiques, aussi différents qu'ils puissent être les uns des autres,
peuvent néanmoins incarner la même structure mathématique et causale
et l'incarner de plus en plus à mesure que le temps passe.
Nous sommes donc un dépôt chimique qui est différent. Ce dépôt chimique possède une universalité.
Sa structure contient, avec une précision toujours croissante,
la structure de tout. Cet endroit, et aucun autre endroit dans l'univers,
est un centre qui contient en son sein l'essence structurelle et causale de
l'ensemble du reste de la réalité physique. Et donc, loin d'être insignifiant,
le fait que les lois de la physique permettent ceci, voire en délèguent la réalisation,
est une des choses les plus importantes à propos du monde physique.
Maintenant comment le système solaire -- et notre environnement, dans son aspect humain --
acquiert cette relation particulière avec le reste de l'univers ?
Une chose qui est vraie dans la remarque de Stephen Hawking -- je veux dire, elle est vraie,
mais ce n'est pas la bonne emphase. Une chose vraie là-dedans c'est qu'il
n'utilise aucune physique spéciale pour cela. Il n'y a aucune dispensation particulière,
aucun miracle impliqué. Il y parvient avec trois choses que nous avons ici en abondance.
L'une d'entre elles c'est la matière, parce que la croissance de la connaissance
est une forme de traitement de l'information. Le traitement de l'information
est du calcul, le calcul requiert un ordinateur --
il n'y a aucun moyen connu de fabriquer un ordinateur sans matière.
Nous avons aussi besoin d'énergie pour fabriquer l'ordinateur, et plus important,
pour fabriquer le média sur lequel est inscrite en pratique la connaissance que nous découvrons.
Et puis troisièmement, moins tangible, mais aussi essentielle pour la création illimitée
de connaissance, d'explications, c'est la preuve.
Notre environnement est inondé par des preuves.
Il nous arrive d'aller faire un tour pour tester -- disons, la Loi de la Gravité de Newton
-- il y a environ 300 ans.
Mais la preuve que nous avons utilisée pour faire ça tombait sur chaque mètre carré
de la Terre depuis des milliards d'années avant, et continuera de tomber pendant des milliards d'années
après. La même chose est vraie pour toutes les autres sciences.
Pour autant que nous le sachions, la preuve pour découvrir les vérités les plus fondamentales
de toutes les sciences est ici à notre portée sur notre planète.
Nous sommes en un lieu saturé de preuves, et aussi de matière et d'énergie.
Au dehors, dans l'espace intergalactique, ces trois pré-requis
pour la création illimitée de connaissance sont en quantité la plus infinitésimale possible.
Comme je l'ai dit, c'est vide, c'est froid, et c'est sombre. N'est-ce pas ?
En fait, c'est encore une autre fausse idée de clocher. (Rires)
Parce que, imaginez un cube là-bas dans l'espace intergalactique, de la même taille que
notre maison, le système solaire. Certes ce cube est très vide d'un point de vue humain,
mais ça signifie quand même qu'il contient plus d'un million de tonnes de matière.
Et un million de tonnes c'est suffisant pour construire, disons, une station spatiale autonome,
sur laquelle se trouverait une colonie de scientifiques dévoués à la création d'un
flux ininterrompu de connaissance, etc...
Bon, c'est bien au-delà de notre technologie actuelle, ne serait-ce que de rassembler l'hydrogène
depuis l'espace intergalactique et de le combiner en d'autres éléments, etc...
Mais ce qui est sûr, dans un univers compréhensible,
si quelque chose n'est pas interdit par les lois de la physique,
alors qu'est-ce qui pourrait bien nous empêcher de le faire, en dehors d'ignorer comment ?
En d'autres mots, c'est une question de connaissance, pas de ressources.
Et la même... -- bon, si on pouvait faire ça, on aurait automatiquement une source d'énergie,
parce que la transmutation serait un réacteur à fusion -- et la preuve ?
Eh bien, à nouveau, il fait sombre là-bas pour nos sens humains. Mais tout ce que vous avez à faire c'est
de prendre un télescope, y compris un fabriqué de nos jours,
d'y regarder et vous verrez les mêmes galaxies que vous voyez d'ici.
Avec un télescope plus puissant, vous pourrez voir les étoiles, et les planètes
dans ces galaxies; vous pourrez faire de l'astrophysique, et apprendre les lois de la physique.
Et localement vous pourrez y construire des accélérateurs de particules,
et apprendre la physique des particules élémentaires, et la chimie, etc...
La science la plus difficile à mener serait probablement les sorties sur le terrain en biologie, parce que ça prendrait
plusieurs centaines de millions d'années pour se rendre sur la plus proche planète habitable et en revenir.
Mais je dois vous dire -- et pardon, Richard --
je n'ai jamais vraiment aimé les sorties sur le terrain en biologie,
et je pense qu'on doit pouvoir s'arranger pour n'en faire qu'une toutes les quelques centaines
de millions d'années. (Rires)
Donc en fait, l'espace intergalactique contient tous les pré-requis pour la création
illimitée de connaissance. N'importe lequel de ces cubes, où que ce soit dans l'univers,
pourrait devenir le même type de centre que nous sommes,
si tant est que le savoir-faire puisse s'y trouver.
Nous ne sommes donc pas dans un lieu particulièrement hospitalier.
Si l'espace intergalactique est capable de créer un flux ininterrompu d'explications,
alors quasiment tout autre environnement le peut. La Terre le peut. Une Terre polluée le peut.
Le facteur limitant, là-bas et ici, ce ne sont pas les ressources, parce qu'elles sont abondantes,
mais la connaissance, qui est rare.
Alors cette vision de sapience cosmique peut -- et je pense, devrait
-- flatter notre sentiment d'être exceptionnel. Mais elle devrait aussi nous faire prendre conscience de notre vulnérabilité,
parce que ça veut dire que sans la connaissance spécifique requise
pour survivre aux défis incessants de l'univers, nous ne leur survivrons pas.
Il suffit qu'une supernova se déclenche à quelques années-lumière d'ici, et on est tous morts !
Martin Rees a récemment écrit un livre au sujet de notre vulnérabilité à toutes sortes de choses,
des phénomènes astrophysiques aux expériences scientifiques qui dérapent,
au terrorisme avec les armes de destruction massive, la plus largement traitée.
Il considère que la civilisation n'a que 50% de chances de survivre à ce siècle.
Je pense qu'il va aborder le sujet plus tard dans la conférence.
Je ne pense pas que les probabilités soient le domaine adéquat à l'examen de cette question.
Mais je suis d'accord avec lui là-dessus. Nous pouvons survivre, et nous pouvons succomber.
Ça ne dépend pourtant pas de la chance, mais de si nous créons la connaissance pertinente à temps.
Le danger n'est pas sans précédent du tout. Des espèces s'éteignent tout le temps.
Des civilisations disparaissent. L'écrasante majorité de toutes les espèces et de toutes
les civilisations qui aient jamais existé font partie du passé.
Si nous voulons être l'exception à cela, alors logiquement notre seul espoir
est de faire usage de la caractéristique qui distingue notre espèce,
et notre civilisation, de toutes les autres.
Son nom: notre relation particulière avec les lois de la physique.
Notre capacité à créer de nouvelles explications, une nouvelle connaissance -- d'être un centre de l'existence.
Laissez-moi donc maintenant appliquer ceci à une polémique d'actualité,
ce n'est pas que je veuille plaider pour l'une ou l'autre solution,
mais juste pour illustrer le genre de choses dont je veux parler.
La polémique est le réchauffement planétaire.
Je suis un physicien, mais pas le bon type de physicien. En ce qui concerne le réchauffement planétaire,
je suis juste un profane. La chose rationnelle à faire pour un profane est de prendre au sérieux
la théorie scientifique qui prévaut. Selon cette théorie,
c'est déjà trop tard pour éviter un désastre.
Parce que s'il est vrai que notre meilleure option actuellement est d'éviter les émissions de CO2
avec quelque chose comme le Protocole de Kyoto, avec ses contraintes sur l'activité économique
et son coût énorme de centaines de milliards de dollars ou peu importe combien,
alors c'est déjà un désastre à tous les niveaux de raisonnement.
Les actions qui sont préconisées ne sont même pas censées résoudre le problème, juste le repousser un peu.
Donc c'est déjà trop tard pour l'éviter, et c'est probablement trop tard
bien avant que qui que ce soit n'ait réalisé le danger.
C'était probablement déjà trop tard dans les années 70, quand la meilleure
théorie scientifique disponible nous disait que les émissions industrielles
étaient sur le point de nous précipiter dans une ère glaciaire au cours de laquelle des milliards de personnes mourraient.
Maintenant, la leçon à en tirer me semble claire,
et je ne sais pas pourquoi cela ne nourrit pas le débat public.
C'est qu'on ne peut pas toujours savoir. Quand nous connaissons l'imminence d'un désastre,
et que nous savons comment le résoudre à un coût moindre que celui du désastre lui-même,
alors il n'y aura guère de polémique, vraiment.
Mais aucune précaution, et aucun principe de précaution,
ne peut éviter des problèmes que nous ne prévoyons même pas.
Ainsi nous devons adopter une attitude de réparation des problèmes, pas seulement d'esquive des problèmes.
Il est vrai qu'un gramme de prévention équivaut à un kilo de réparation,
mais uniquement si nous savons quoi éviter.
Si vous avez été frappé sur le nez, alors la science de la médecine ne consiste
pas à vous apprendre comment éviter de prendre des coups.
Si la science médicale s'arrêtait de chercher des remèdes et se concentrait exclusivement sur la prévention,
alors elle n'accomplirait que très peu des deux.
Le monde bourdonne actuellement autour de projets de réductions
des émissions de gaz à tout prix.
Il devrait bourdonner autour de projets pour réduire la température,
et autour de projets pour vivre à plus haute température.
Et pas à tout prix, mais efficacement et à moindre frais. De tels projets existent,
des choses comme des essaims de miroirs dans l'espace pour dévier la lumière du soleil,
et encourager les organismes aquatiques à manger plus de dioxyde de carbone.
Pour le moment, ces choses sont des recherches périphériques.
Elles ne sont pas centrales dans l'effort humain pour affronter ce problème, ou les problèmes en général.
Et pour des problèmes dont nous ne sommes pas encore conscients, la capacité de réparer --
et pas la véritable chance d'éviter indéfiniment -- est notre seul espoir,
non seulement de résolution des problèmes, mais de survie.
Alors, prenez deux tablettes en pierre, et gravez dessus.
Sur l'une d'entre elles, gravez "Les problèmes sont résolubles."
Et sur l'autre gravez "Les problèmes sont inévitables."
Merci. (Applaudissements)